in this talk I want to tell you about
tensor flow and what can you do with it
as a gopher and what I hope your
takeaway will be is taking at home and
trying to give it a go
you've probably all heard of tensor flow
it's in short an edge end-to-end open
source machine learning platform and
last week the alpha 2.0 was released so
now you can use it for heavy lifting in
the Google cloud doing things like using
their CPUs and GPUs and also the TP use
the tons are processing units you could
use it for IOT and for mobile and you
can just serve it over the web to
generalize the steps of machine learning
are you take a problem with a finite to
gather the data you prepare it you
choose your model your trainer model you
evaluate your model tune what needs to
be tuned and then you predict anything
that can be done by a computer is
covered by tensorflow
and the way that it works is that you
have a tensor which is this mathematical
representation that has a datatype and
it has a dimension with a shape which is
the number of dimensions a number of
values per dimension and then you have
the graph or the model which is a group
of nodes each one represents a
mathematical operation and then your
data or the tensors they flow through
this graph and they're undergoing
mathematical operations and at any point
you can inspect the value if this makes
you think of concurrency parallelism and
this sketch you're not alone and this
logic is also what made me try tenza
flow and go and now it's a very good
time to tell you I studied computer
engineering I did chip design I did four
years of go and now I'm doing
observability what I'm not is not a
machine learning engineer and I'm not a
data scientist but I managed to do cool
machine learning stuff using deco API
for tensor flow one of the things that I
did is hack this CAPTCHA the full code
is available there and it was part of
the challenge that you can
see here and this is actually running
the go code and it takes this CAPTCHA
and the output of it is as you can see
UWA G they DJ it's actually working
pretty cool if you want to give it a try
there's great documentation you can use
the current stable version is one point
13 maybe reminding a bit of the go
latest stable version but it's actually
only three years old and last week the
Alpha 2.0 was released both supporting
go API is pretty cool also both are
linking to the go dog so we're all
landing in a comfortable place if you
want to give it a try it is worth
mentioning that both tons of flow and
machine learning in general is mostly
supported for Python for obvious reasons
and the Python API is the only one that
is has the stability problem promise and
it's and it's the only one that allows
you to build models using the API but to
build a model you'd need not only to
know Python you also need to have very
strong mathematical background as a go
developer what you mostly need to do
would be either training or consuming
the models both are covered with a go
api's so please give it a go and try it
in production or for your personal
products thank you
[Applause]